Ich habe sicher die Hälfte
vergessen, wie immer.
Auch Jonas
hat einen wichtigen Tag vor sich:
Heute beginnt die Schweizermeis-
terschaft im Segelkunstflug.
Tschüss.
- Gut, tschüss, viel Glück.
Dir gutes Ausschlafen.
- Pass auf dich auf.
Für die Teilnahme
in der höchsten Kategorie Unlimited
hat der Schweizer Hoffnungsträger
das letzte halbe Jahr hart trainiert.
Vor einer Woche
hat Jonas dann erfahren,
dass er der einzige Pilot
in dieser Kategorie ist.
Ein eigentlicher Wettkampf
findet deshalb nicht statt
und Jonas
darf nur ausser Konkurrenz starten.
Ich begrüsse euch herzlich
zu diesem engen Piloten-Briefing.
Speziell möchte ich die
Punktrichter/-innen begrüssen.
Der Chefpunktrichter
ist George Dörder.
Er hat das letzte Wort.
Beim Briefing dann
die grosse Überraschung:
Jonas wird heute doch nicht
ausser Konkurrenz fliegen.
Ich erfuhr gerade, dass ich
doch einen Konkurrenten habe.
Er hat schon Erfahrung
mit Weltmeisterschaften.
Darum wird es doch noch spannend
bei uns.
Er hat mit dem österreichischen
Piloten Siegfried Meier
einen Konkurrenten mit Weltmeister-
schaftsrfahrung bekommen.
Das wird vermutlich ein ganz
interessantes Rennen geben.
Sigi Meier,
ein österreichischer Pilot,
hat sich im letzten Moment
noch angemeldet.
Jetzt ist fertig lustig.
- Wir haben uns schon gesehen.
Er startet vor Jonas
und fliegt sein erstes Programm.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Die Jury am Boden entscheidet,
ob die Figuren präzise und elegant
geflogen werden.
Wer mehr Punkte erzielt,
hat gewonnen.
So, jetzt.
- Er ist nicht senkrecht.
Ja, gut.
Jonas und sein Trainer Torsten
beobachten den Österreicher genau -
und mit einer kleinen Portion
Schadenfreude.
Schulterwurf.
Hätte das ein Weibchen sein müssen?
- Nein, ein Männchen, oder?
Wenn der andere etwas patzt,
freut man sich schon ein wenig.
Das muss ich zugeben - ein wenig.
Zwei Nuller, oder?
Der Konkurrent hat sich
ein paar Patzer erlaubt.
Eine gute Ausgangslage für Jonas,
der zum ersten Mal
in dieser höchsten Kategorie startet.
Zwar kann er heute
keinen Titel gewinnen,
zwei Teilnehmer sind zu wenig.
Aber er kann seine Punkte
mit dem Konkurrenten vergleichen
und seine Leistung einordnen.
Ich bin gespannt, was er fliegt.
* Treibende, elektronische Klänge *
Oh, scheisse!
Das war nix. Er war zu langsam,
wartete zu lange.
Jawohl. Ah, ein bisschen
nachgesteuert.
Jawohl! Ah, der war nix.
Der war sehr teuer.
Vielleicht sind noch zwei Punkte
übrig geblieben - oder einer.
Ja, Mist, schade.
Aber sonst war's nicht schlecht.
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Schnaubend) Ach.
- Ja?
Jetzt übst du noch zwei, drei Jahre,
dann wird das schon.
Genau, so kommt es mir auch vor.
Die Schadenfreude
hat den Sieg ereilt.
Ein wenig enttäuscht von meinem Flug
bin ich schon.
V.a. weil ich dachte,
den kann ich schön fliegen,
es sind Figuren, die ich gut kann.
Diesen Flug kann Sigi
definitiv schöner fliegen.
Den kann er besser,
als ich ihn geflogen bin.
Was die Jury meint,
erfährt Jonas erst am nächsten Tag,
nach einem zweiten Flug.
Eine letzte Chance hat er also noch.
Ah, hier ist sie.
Ich hatte das Handy nicht dabei,
sorry, hoi. - Hoi.
Anna hat sich spontan entschieden,
ihren Freund in Thun zu besuchen.
Die Überraschung ist gelungen. Jonas
freut sich über die Unterstützung.
Ich hoffe, ich kann ein wenig
helfen. - Helfen?
Ja, dich mental unterstützen.
- Okay, krass.
Das würde nicht jede Freundin
mitmachen,
dass sie so verständnisvoll ist
und an Wettbewerbe mitkommt.
Und ich finde es cool, wenn sie sich
auch integrieren kann.
und sie merkt,
dass das gute Leute sind -
auch wenn sie oft
über das Segelfliegen sprechen.
Im US-Bundesstaat Colorado
ist das Wetter genauso schlecht
wie die Laune der beiden Tornadojäger
Dominic und Sascha.
Ihre vielversprechende Gewitterzelle
hat sich vor ihren Augen
in Luft aufgelöst.
Ich brauche jeweils einen kurzen
Moment, um mich zurückzubesinnen,
denn die Enttäuschung ist da.
Man schaut Modelle an, man fragt
sich, ob man am richtigen Ort ist.
Und auf einmal sieht man,
wie alles zusammenfällt.
Ein Jahr lang haben die zwei Freunde
für diese dreiwöchige Reise gespart.
Das Ziel war es, ein paar tolle Fotos
eines Tornados nach Hause zu bringen.
Doch bis heute haben die beiden
nur Regen und Wolken gesehen.
Wie sieht es südlich aus?
- Noch nichts.
Ich wollte noch das Satellitenbild
anschauen.
Vielleicht hier.
Hier kommt keines, oder?
- Nein.
Vielleicht ganz knapp,
aber es fällt alles zusammen.
Nicht einmal der starke Niederschlag
nützt uns.
Ganz wenig West ...
- Ich würde leicht West machen.
Eine Weile vergehen lassen
und dann den Aufwind anschauen.
Das ist das Schönste, was wir
machen können - oder siehst du ...
Nein. Jetzt warten wir diese Zelle
ab und schauen, was passiert.
Dominic und Sascha fahren
einmal mehr in Richtung Denver.
Im Norden von Colorado
sei die Tornadowahrscheinlichkeit
momentan sehr gross -
sagen ihre Berechnungen.
Tatsächlich
braut sich ein Sturm zusammen.
Die beiden entdecken
direkt vor ihnen eine Gewitterzelle.
Haben die beiden tatsächlich
einen möglichen Tornado vor sich?
Dort wäre der Entstehungspunkt
eines Tornados.
Aber ... Wir schauen mal.
Man sieht eine sog. Wallcloud,
dort hat es Aufwind.
Auf der rechten Seite
sieht man ein Schwänzchen,
da geht es hoch, und in der Mitte
sieht man ein Wölkchen.
Das kommt weiter nach unten
als das rundherum.
Rotiert das?
- Ja, das ist ein Tornado.
Und zwar ein grosser.
Kannst du aufmachen, bitte?
Ja, ah, scheisse.
- Danke.
Von einem Tornado spricht man erst,
wenn die Luftspirale auch tatsächlich
den Boden berührt.
Ah, Tornado!
Es geht immer hoch und runter -
vielleicht gibt es mal Bodenkontakt.
Man sieht die Rotation der Wall-
cloud, man sieht, wie sie rotiert.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Das war wohl schon alles.
Mal schauen,
aber es sieht nicht gut aus.
Dort kommt aber auch etwas runter.
Nur ein Foto
würde Dominic schon reichen.
Wir haben das GPS-Signal verloren,
wir sind wahrscheinlich zu nahe.
Das GPS-Signal fiel raus.
Wir müssen weiter.
Es ist wirklich haarscharf,
ca. 500 m zurück.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Die neue PC-12
der Okavango Air Rescue
ist inzwischen über dem Mittelmeer,
kurz vor Ägypten.
Chefpilot Aldo und seine beiden
Passagiere Misha und Christian
sind seit fünf Tagen unterwegs.
Nach vier Zwischenstopps
legen sie in Luxor eine Pause ein.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wir sind in Luxor, in Ägypten.
Wir sind gestern
bis hierher geflogen.
Jetzt warten wir hier auf die
Overflight Permission für Sudan.
Wir fragten vor zwei Wochen an
und haben sie noch nicht bekommen.
Vielleicht müssen wir auch
noch irgendjemandem
ein paar Dollar zahlen.
Es ist gut möglich,
dass jemand im Militär im Sudan
diese Erlaubnis nicht herausgibt,
weil er ein Bakschisch will.
Dieses arabische Trinkgeld
wird vielleicht sogar nötig sein.
Aldo kann keine Alternativroute
nach Botswana finden.
Also, wir können Saudi-Arabien
auch vergessen.
Es dauert einen Monat, um vielleicht
eine Überflugserlaubnis zu bekommen.
Ich schaue nun,
ob ich etwas vom Sudan höre
und lasse es euch wissen.
Ja, wir müssen einfach warten.
Wir werden sehen, was passiert
und schauen dann weiter.
Seit vier Jahren lebt Familie Moser
aus dem Kanton Bern hier in Osttimor,
in Südostasien -
einem der ärmsten Länder der Welt.
Was soll ich uns denn heute
zum Mittagessen kochen?
Daniel arbeitet hier
als Missionspilot
bei der christlichen
Hilfsorganisation MAF.
Es begann alles
vor gut dreieinhalb Jahren.
In einem Strandhäuschen,
wir waren vier oder fünf Familien.
Sie sind alle wieder zu Hause -
in Australien und Neuseeland.
Das Ehepaar diskutiert oft,
ob und wann sie in die Schweiz
zurückgehen wollen.
Deborah macht sich Gedanken darüber,
wie Sohn Eli aufwächst.
Ja, das putzen wir gleich.
Wenn die Kinder zu alt sind,
kann es vielleicht schwierig sein,
sie zu entwurzeln,
anderswo wieder einzupflanzen.
Er hat hier sein Zuhause,
Osttimor ist für ihn normal.
Und nicht die Schweiz.
Das dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Wir überlegen uns,
wie lange wir hier sind,
wann es Zeit ist,
zurück in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Familie Moser ist wegen Daniels Job
nach Osttimor gezogen.
Der Rettungspilot fliegt
täglich Einsätze auf der Insel.
Ein Flugtransport kann hier
über Leben und Tod entscheiden.
Ich bekam eine Meldung:
eine ca. 35-jährige Frau,
die schwanger ist.
Sie hat ziemlich starke
Wehen und Schmerzen.
Dann zählt manchmal jede Minute.
Daniel ist immer allein mit der
kleinen Propellermaschine unterwegs.
So kann er möglichst viele Passagiere
und medizinisches Personal
transportieren.
* Leises Stöhnen *
Die schwangere Frau war bis zum
Flugplatz schon 6 Std. unterwegs.
Sie braucht dringend ärztliche Hilfe.
* Stöhnen, Gesprächsfetzen *
Ich habe schon Respekt
vor Schwangeren-Transporten.
Und trotzdem machen wir das
eigentlich am häufigsten.
* Schreien, Stöhnen *
Die Geburt steht kurz bevor.
Ob Mutter und Kind
die Komplikationen überstehen,
wird Daniel
erst am nächsten Tag erfahren.
Seine Aufgabe als Rettungspilot
endet für heute.
Vor ein paar Wochen in Andwil SG
waren Stefan und sein Copilot Urs
voller Vorfreude.
Sie wollten die Sonnenfinsternis
in Argentinien
aus ihrem Heissluftballon heraus
beobachten.
In Argentinien
ist dann die Sonnenfinsternis.
Weisst du, wie das geht?
Nicht? Schau, hier ist die Erde
und dort oben die Sonne.
Die Sonne
scheint immer auf die Erde.
Jetzt kommt noch der Mond
und ist dazwischen.
Jetzt gibt es einen Moment -
schau mal.
Da verdeckt der Mond die Sonne.
Der Mond wirft so einen Schatten
auf einen kleinen Punkt der Erde.
Und dort ist die Sonnenfinsternis.
Mit dieser Expedition will sich
Stefan einen Herzenswunsch erfüllen.
Eine totale Sonnenfinsternis
aus dem Heissluftballon zu sehen -
diese Chance gibt's wahrscheinlich
nur einmal im Leben.
Heute ist es so weit.
Zusammen mit 50 anderen Piloten
möchte sich Stefan
diesen unglaublichen Moment
auf keinen Fall entgehen lassen.
Das gibt sagenhafte Bilder.
Die totale Sonnenfinsternis
dauert etwas mehr als 2 Min.
Dann muss man zur richtigen Zeit
am richtigen Ort sein.
Das Timing ist so: Um 17.30
müssen wir in der Luft sein.
Wir beginnen um 17 Uhr, die Ballone
aufzublasen und aufzuheizen,
sodass jeder um 17.30 Uhr
startklar ist.
Ich habe schon als Kind
eine Sonnenfinsternis gesehen.
Ansonsten hatten wir
in der Schweiz extrem Pech -
auch bei der totalen 1999,
das Wetter war immer schlecht.
Ich habe noch nie eine totale
Sonnenfinsternis gesehen
und freue mich extrem darauf.
Ursprünglich
kam der Wind eher von Südosten,
darum richteten wir zuerst auch in
diese Richtung ein, das war perfekt.
Die meisten begannen,
die Ballone aufzublasen.
19 oder 20 Ballone.
Um 17.10 Uhr
hat der Wind plötzlich gedreht.
Das passierte schlagartig.
Wir müssen drehen.
Die Luft rauslassen!
Oben halten, oben halten!
Darum waren wir komplett falsch. Der
Wind kam von oben gegen den Ballon.
Gegen den Wind kann man
den Ballon nicht aufstellen.
Wir mussten zuerst alles umdrehen.
Wann ist die Sonnenfinsternis?
Jetzt gibt es doch noch Stress.
Wir müssen oben halten,
hier rauf lassen.
Wenn die Luft draussen ist, drehen.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Die 20 Teams müssen ihre Ballone so
schnell wie möglich neu platzieren.
Sonst wird es zu dunkel, um überhaupt
noch rechtzeitig starten zu können.
Alles rauslassen. Fest ziehen!
Loslassen, loslassen!
Hier lassen wir raus.
Stefan gehört zu den erfahrensten
Piloten auf dem Platz.
Er rennt von Ballon zu Ballon,
um den anderen zu helfen.
Sobald wir einen Pick-up haben,
holen wir einen.
Willst du aufstellen,
bei diesem Wind? - Ja, ja.
Es war ein totales Chaos.
I can't hold the car!
Es war zu viel Wind, um vernünftig,
im offenen Feld starten zu können.
Urs, pass bitte auf!
No, no, no, Joseph!
No, it's too early!
Why he took off like this?
It was clear that it was too early.
Das hätte nicht sein müssen, es war
doch klar, dass es viel zu früh war.
So ein Scheiss.
Ein paar Ballonpiloten haben es
geschafft: Sie sind in der Luft.
Stefan und sein Team
gehören nicht dazu.
Das Hauptproblem ist,
dass es zu viel Zeug hat hier.
Wenn man alleine wäre, könnte man
los in die Windrichtung.
Der Wind flacht eher ab.
Wären wir doch
30 Min. früher gestartet.
Aber jetzt
ist es wieder viel besser.
Ja, das dachte ich auch,
darum warteten wir.
Wir holen uns sofort einen Pick-up.
Die Franzosen brauchen sofort
einen Pick-up, Urs.
Dann ging der Wind
für einen Moment deutlich zurück.
Da konnte man es versuchen.
Wenn es so bleibt, starten wir.
Ein letzter Versuch:
Das Gewicht des Autos soll den Ballon
so lange wie nötig am Boden behalten.
Aber direkt neben Stefan
startet bereits ein anderer -
und der versperrt ihm den Weg.
Stefan versucht zu helfen,
um endlich selber starten zu können.
Away, away, away!
Come here!
Hey, jetzt müsst ihr aufhören.
Haltet die Leine hier,
haltet die Leine!
Ich weiss jetzt nicht,
was hier passiert ist.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik,
Stimmengewirr *
* Hupen, Jubel *
Auch dieser Ballon
schafft es noch in die Luft.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob wir das machen wollen.
Die Sonnenfinsternis
ist sowieso bald komplett.
Nur Stefan
bleibt auf dem Boden zurück.
We stay on the ground,
because it's too late.
Wir beobachten jetzt, ob der Wind
zurückgeht, das ist möglich.
Wenn nicht,
werden wir wohl nicht fahren.
I think it's too late.
* Orientalisch anmutende Musik *
In Luxor wartet das Team der Okavango
Air Rescue seit zwei Tagen
auf eine Überflugbewilligung
aus dem Sudan.
Heute ist Mittwoch, der 29.,
wir sind gegroundet.
Wir haben keine Chance,
hier wegzukommen.
Wir hoffen,
dass wir am Montag irgendwann
die Genehmigung von Eritrea
bekommen.
Mehr wissen wir momentan nicht.
Pilot Aldo kann sich nicht erklären,
warum die Bewilligung
so lange auf sich warten lässt -
bis er die Nachrichten einschaltet:
Im Sudan startet die Opposition
einen zweitägigen Streik
gegen das Militärregime.
Der Streik
erklärt das Schweigen der Behörden -
und verheisst nichts Gutes.
Einen Snag oder Pepin muss man
ja einplanen auf so einer Reise.
Das ist gar nicht anders möglich.
Also versucht man,
sich anderweitig zu unterhalten.
* Orientalisch anmutende Musik *
* Melancholischer Popsong:
"Bohemian Rhampsody" von Queen *
(Alle, leicht falsch)
# Too late, my time has come.
# Send shivers down my spine.
# Body's aching all the time.
# Goodbye everybody, I've got to go.
# Gotta leave you all behind
and face the truth.
# Mama, oh ...
Der nächste Wettkampftag in Thun.
Jonas macht sich
für seinen zweiten Flug bereit.
Links, rechts, jetzt kannst du
oben drauf drücken.
Seine Freundin Anna
ist als moralische Stütze dabei.
Viel Glück.
- Danke.
* Treibende Klänge *
Beim gestrigen Flug
waren zu viele Patzer drin.
Heute muss der 25-Jährige
perfekt fliegen,
um neben seinem erfahrenen
Konkurrenten aus Österreich
nicht unterzugehen.
* Treibende Klänge *
Und?
- Das war nicht gut.
Ich finde, es sah gut aus.
* Lachen *
Auch heute ist Jonas nicht ganz
zufrieden mit seiner Leistung.
Aber die Entscheidung liegt jetzt
ganz bei den Punkterichtern.
Wir kommen zur höchsten
Kategorie, es gab zwei Teilnehmer.
In dieser Kategorie
gibt es keine Wertung.
Es gibt eigentlich
keinen ersten und zweiten Platz,
sondern den ersten Sieger
und den zweiten Sieger.
Der zweite Sieger
in der Kategorie Unlimited ist ...
Sigi Meier.
Und der erste Sieger ist Jonas,
herzlichen Glückwünsch.
Jonas hat mehr Punkte bekommen als
sein österreichischer Konkurrent -
selbst er
ist ein bisschen überrascht.
Der strenge Juror George erklärt,
warum der Schweizer
trotzdem gewonnen hat.
Gut gemacht.
- Aber knapp.
Sigi ist die Rolle falsch geflogen.
Er hat 70 Strafrunden geholt,
das war dein Sieg.
So einfach ist es.
- Ja, aber nicht so ehrenvoll.
Das wird immer wieder so sein.
Wir sehen dich
bei der Weltmeisterschaft, oder?
Ja, ich habe es vor.
- Ja, klar.
Die Leistung ist auf jeden Fall
ausbaufähig.
Wenn er dranbleibt, sehe ich ihn
international bald in den Top 10.
Es freut mich natürlich besonders,
dass ich nicht noch zehn Jahre
Unlimited fliegen muss,
bis ich an die WM gehen kann.
Ja, ich denke ... Das ist schön.
Jonas kann sich jetzt in Ruhe
auf die Weltmeisterschaft
im nächsten Jahr vorbereiten.
Und vielleicht war dieser Tag
der Anfang einer grossen Karriere.
In Osttimor ist Missionspilot Daniel
auf dem Weg ins Spital.
Er will dort die Patienten besuchen,
die er in den letzten Tagen
im Flugzeug transportiert hat.
Meine Gefühle sind etwas gespalten.
Wenn es ein Happy End gibt, ist man
selbst jeweils auch glücklicher.
Aber die Realität ist, dass der
Bestattungsraum relativ gross ist.
Es kann also auch so sein.
Die medizinische Versorgung
hier in Osttimor
steht in keinem Vergleich
zur Schweiz.
Die Sterblichkeitsrate
lag letztes Jahr bei 46 %.
Es ist krass, wenn fast die Hälfte
in einer Holzkiste endet.
Das zeigt einmal mehr,
dass es uns hier noch braucht.
Daniel besucht das Spital nur selten.
Die Schicksale gehen ihm oft zu nah.
Ah, that's the kid.
Er trifft den elfjährigen Jungen
aus Same,
den er mit akutem Denguefieber
ins Spital geflogen hat.
Es geht ihm schon viel besser.
He looks much better.
- Yeah, he's getting better.
Das will man natürlich immer sehen.
Das ist schön.
Im Raum nebenan liegt das Baby,
das kaum mehr atmen konnte.
Daniel erkennt die Eltern wieder.
Very good to see.
Es gab schon Momente, in denen
das Baby keinen Mucks mehr machte
und ich Angst hatte,
dass etwas nicht gut war.
Darum ist es umso schöner zu sehen,
wie es atmet
und dass es ihm gut geht.
Ich hoffe, es kann bald wieder
nach Hause zu seiner Familie.
Daniel erkundigt sich auch
nach der schwangeren Frau vom Vortag.
Das Kind ist also gestorben.
Und die Mutter, hat sie überlebt?
Immerhin, das ist gut.
Das macht natürlich
schon ein wenig traurig.
Und ich merke, dass ich
irgendwie abblocken muss.
Ich kann morgen nicht ins Flugzeug
sitzen mit diesem Gedanken.
Dann denke ich lieber an die anderen
zwei, denen es gut geht.
Und die Mutter hat überlebt, das
hätte sie sonst vielleicht nicht.
Man muss
auf die Sonnenseite schauen.
Das Leben als Rettungspilot
ist kein einfaches.
Aber Daniel
hat sich bewusst dafür entschieden
und seine Frau Deborah
unterstützt ihn auf diesem Weg.
Die schönen Seiten
dieses armen Landes
trösten die beiden immer wieder
über ihr Heimweh
und die vielen Entbehrungen hinweg.
Irgendwann werden wir ganz zurück
in die Schweiz gehen, das ist klar.
Nicht klar ist, wann. Heute und
morgen wohl noch nicht gerade.
Es ist noch nicht Zeit,
hier zusammenzupacken.
Wir haben beide das Gefühl, wir
haben hier noch etwas zu erledigen,
und es gefällt uns grundsätzlich
in Osttimor.
Ja, es ist noch nicht Zeit,
zusammenzupacken.
Der Weg hierher war zu lange,
als dass wir jetzt nach vier Jahren
schon wieder zusammenpacken.
Irgendwann wird das ein Thema sein,
aber im Moment noch nicht.
Und so wird Familie Moser
diesen Weg noch eine Weile gehen.
Damit Daniel den Einheimischen
aus der Luft helfen kann -
mit der Unterstützung von ganz oben.
Hast du Sand in den Augen?
Wohl eher Salz.
- (Lachend) Salz?
Der Mond schiebt sich
immer mehr über die Sonne.
Bald herrscht über den argentinischen
Anden eine totale Sonnenfinsternis.
Die letzten Heissluftballons
sind gestartet.
Aber Stefan und sein Team
sind noch am Boden -
und dort werden sie auch bleiben.
Ich bin enttäuscht,
dass es nicht geklappt hat,
weil wir ganz nahe dran waren.
Nachdem sie endlich
genug Platz hatten,
war es bereits zu dunkel,
um sicher zu starten.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Jubel, Applaus *
Wow!
Incredible. Look, the balloon!
Es war ein emotionaler Moment, mir
lief es kalt den Rücken hinunter.
Und dann noch die Ballons oben -
wenn sie heizten,
leuchteten sie wie Lampions.
Und doch schmerzt es ein wenig,
weil man weiss,
dass fünf oder sechs Ballons starten
und das beobachten konnten.
Die Sicherheit
steht bei so etwas an erster Stelle.
Das muss man immer auch realistisch
und vernünftig anschauen.
Diese Chance hat Stefan verpasst.
Dafür kehren er und sein Team
gesund nach Hause zurück.
* Muezzin-Rufe *
In Luxor sind mittlerweile
fünf Tage vergangen.
Aber heute Morgen
haben Misha, Christian und Aldo
endlich gute Nachrichten bekommen:
Die Überflugserlaubnis für den Sudan
ist eingetroffen.
Jetzt kann die neue Pilatus PC-12 die
letzte Etappe nach Botswana antreten.
* Rockige, energiegeladene Musik *
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Zwei Wochen waren sie unterwegs.
12'000 km Luftlinie - von Montreal,
Kanada nach Botswana, Afrika.
Hier kann die PC-12
nun ihren neuen Zweck erfüllen:
Patienten transportieren
und Leben retten.
Das Team der Okawango Air Rescue
hat Menschen und Maschine
schon sehnsüchtig erwartet.
Welcome back.
- Thank you.
Welcome to the family.
So viele Emotionen.
Wir haben's geschafft.
Und jetzt wird mir erst bewusst:
Wir haben's tatsächlich geschafft.
Die Rettungsflugwacht von Okawango
hat nun ein zweites
Transportflugzeug.
Noch ein wenig Farbe und dann passt
die PC-12 perfekt zur Flotte.
* Ausrufe, Jubel *
Misha, welcome back!
Welcome back, Sir.
In den USA
bahnt sich etwas Grosses an:
Erneut deutet vieles darauf hin, dass
der grosse Augenblick ganz nah ist.
Jetzt kommt er dann.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wow, geil!
So schön!
- Wir haben's geschafft.
Das reicht wahrscheinlich schon.
* Dramatische Musik *
Tornado! Dort unten!
Er ist dort unten, Tornado!
Und tatsächlich.
Direkt vor ihren Augen
setzt der Wirbel auf dem Boden auf
und ist zum richtigen Tornado
geworden.
Die beiden Stormchaser
haben ihr Ziel erreicht:
ihren eigenen, kleinen Wirbelsturm.
Nein, ich will ihn noch filmen!
Auf meinen Fotos sieht man,
dass er unten am Boden ankommt.
Hier sieht man es nicht gut, aber
wir wissen es wegen der Struktur.
So ein schöner Tornado -
wir wussten erst nicht,
ob er dort drüben aufsetzte.
Hier hatte er Bodenkontakt.
Es ist einfach wunderschön,
das ist absolut genial.
Für diese Fotos sind die beiden
um die halbe Welt gereist
und tagelang durch die USA gefahren.
Da wird sogar Sascha etwas emotional.
Realisierst du es?
Das ist gut.
Über 10'000 km im Auto,
unzählige Stunden vor dem Computer
und unendlich viel Geduld
haben sich gelohnt:
Super.
Dominic möchte diesen Erfolgsmoment
als Erstes mit der Familie
zu Hause teilen.
Hallo, Jonas. Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
Ich konnte einen wunderschönen
Tornado einfangen!
Er war sehr schön.
* Unverständlich *
Ja, er hörte fast nicht mehr auf
zu drehen.
Die Natur hat sich Dominic und Sascha
von ihrer beeindruckendsten Seite
gezeigt.
Genau der richtige Zeitpunkt,
um die Jagd zu beenden.
Die Luft, das Element zum Schweben,
Atmen und Träumen.
Sie bringt immer wieder frischen Wind
in unser Leben.
Und hilft uns, die Antworten
zwischen Himmel und Erde zu finden.
Dank ihr schweben wir auf Wolke 7.
Und sie lässt uns dem stärksten Sturm
standhalten.
Und egal, wie dünn sie manchmal wird,
sorgt sie dafür,
dass wir niemals aufgeben.
* Sanfte, hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Laura Thomann - 2020